il n'y a pas de sujets qui doivent être
tabou et il faut essayer de comprendre
ce qui se passe vous si vous n'aimez pas
les choses vous n'arrivez pas à les
comprendre et donc à les combattre
objectivement si vous prenez les trois
derniers attentats qui ont endeuillé la
france est bien les trois fois c'était
des étrangers donc deux tunisiens 1
c'est sûr et régulière pendant dix ans
un autre qui venait d'arriver et le
troisième celui qui a assassiné la
sémiotique était un tchétchène qui était
arrivée qui était réfugié politique on
voit bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas dans notre système
d'assimilation d'intégration et qui ne
d'immigration
si on prend les par exemple les gens qui
font l'objet d'un asile politique
eh bien eux vous avez chaud page
peut-être me tromper je crois c'est 30 %
des gens qui demandent l'asile politique
qu'ils obtiennent
mais sur ce qu'ils ne le tiennent pas 94
% restent en france quand même on voit
bien que ça ne fonctionne pas nous
devons pouvoir choisir l'immigration
anti-vih et nous vous parlez d'un
dévoiement du droit d'asile
oui bien sûr bien sûr à partir du moment
où tous les gens qui déposent une
demande d'asile qu'il obtienne ou qu'ils
l'obtiennent pas in fine et reste en
france on voit bien que ça n'a plus du
tout sens donc il faut qu'on puisse
choisir notre immigration
ça me paraît être le b à ba et il faut
qu'on puisse renvoyer ceux des étrangers
qui ne conviennent pas en france il ya
deux choses dans cette tribune
d'éléments la tribune elle même moi
personnellement que des militaires
retraités retraités prennent la parole
et fasse une tribune sur un sujet qui
les intéressent je vois pas en quoi ça
pourrait me gênait ça gênait personne
comme madame pulvar par exemple a signé
une tribune dans libération en novembre
2020 extrêmement violentes contre la
police en expliquant que le racisme la
violence gangréner la police française
dont je ne partage évidemment pas cette
idée moi cette tribune mme horriblement
choquer mais j'ai entendu personne qui
disait qui expliquait que madame pulvar
n'avez pas le droit de dire ça donc ça
c'est une chose ce qui me gêne un peu
plus dans cette tribune c'est la
récupération politique qui en est faite
on voit bien que l'extrême droite s'est
précipité dessus en disant que les
militaires viennent à moi l'extrême
gauche se précipitent dessus en temps
monsieur mélenchon qui réclame une fois
n'est pas coutume des plaintes et des
poursuites et qui veut porter plainte
contre les militaires qui ont refait sa
vie ainsi que le gouvernement ait tardé
à réagir
et le gouvernement condamne en disant
qu'ils auraient éventuellement des
sanctions
moi je crois qu'il faut faire attention
l'armée est là pour défendre la nation
l'armée elle est ni de droite ni de
gauche et ne doit pas être un enjeu
politique voilà donc moi j'appelle tout
le monde une certaine réserve sur cette
tribune je j'en parle j'ai pas lu la
tribune je n'en ai entendu que ce qui se
disait
mais un ça ne me choque pas que des
militaires retraités pas des militaires
d'actifs bien sûr puisse prendre la
parole sur un sujet qui les intéressent
et 2 faisons attention de ne pas
politiser ces questions là les questions
de défense et même d'ailleurs les
questions de sécurité sont des questions
qui intéressent tous les français et qui
ne peuvent pas se réduire à un débat
purement politicien